la populaire ruelle graffiti harry à
toronto a revêtit de nouvelles couleurs
au cours des dernières semaines
ou plutôt une nouvelle couleur le noir
il dit walcott juste idée c'était de
prendre des vêtements du nord dans les
médias sociaux il recrée dans le
vraiment prendre un secteur de la ville
leur endroit
mais qui est le projet peindre la ville
en noir est le résultat d'une
collaboration entre une quarantaine
d'artistes un graffiti toronto c'est du
jamais vu
il n'y a jamais eu autant d'artistes qui
ont travaillé sur un projet de cette
envergure à toronto
les artistes qui n'auraient pas
d'ordinaire voulu peindre sur la même
toile ont voulu le faire parce que la
cause touche le coeur de l'humanité
il faut dire que son musée ou galeries
les oeuvres en plein air ont l'avantagé
de satisfaire les amateurs d'art en
sevrage depuis le début de la pandémie
sur drôle a dit aux hystériques vma ses
jeans crise id de s'assurer que le
message est clair
quand les gens marchent dans la rue elle
rapidement ils peuvent comprendre
l'intention derrière de graffitis
histoire de faire voyager le message
l'artiste fed a aussi pas le nom de
dizaines de personnes mortes lors
d'interactions avec des policiers au
canada
la toile un camion semi-remorque doit
traverser la frontière pour participer à
une prochaine marche en la mémoire de
georges pride au minnesota
son oeuvre dans le graffiti ali porte le
message n'aurait peut-être jamais
l'occasion de discuter avec ces
personnes mais de cette manière on peut
voir de pouvoir transformatif dollars
le pouvoir des graffitis de construire
des communautés
les artistes ont intention de continuer
à utiliser leurs aérosol pour alimenter
la discussion sur le racisme systémique
nous sommes des artistes
nous avons le talent nous avons la
peinture si le message est important
nous allons continuer de faire notre
travail si nous pouvons lancer la
conversation
c'est déjà le premier pas vers des
changements même si c'est seulement une
personne un mur à la fois ici quatre
nuls et radio-canada tous beaucoup